all right 16 time grammy award winner
david foster is returning to las vegas
this month i caught up with the producer
and singer alongside his talented wife
catherine mcphee to talk all things
music take a look
[Applause]
the grammys are this weekend it's a big
music weekend new year's eve
in your city in our city we're so
excited
oh hello hello catherine
good how are you and cohort and singer
and extinguisher extraordinaire
and disaster programmings that are in
vegas this weekend i know that's so cool
that it's immigrant and in vegas
so my rule always was if i wasn't
nominated i never went i know that's
kind of stupid but that's my and i'm not
nominated this year uh and so i'm not
going but i i'm sure it's gonna be a
great party and what's that like to be
nominated
it's good it feels good but i know it's
gonna be a party if things are pinned up
for you know two two years now
[Music]
let's talk about the show out here in
vegas it's coming up pretty soon what
can people expect when they come to see
both of you
well it's it's really it's his show this
is let's be honest this is david's show
he has a bunch of singers who come out
that are really amazing singers who help
sort of support um all the wonderful
songs he's written and or produced
and um
he is
unpredictable
funny
um loves to go out to the audience
and uh i just get to you know go out
there and sprinkle a few songs
um i have this intro for cat and the
music starts and then right before she
sings i say ladies and gentlemen kathryn
mcphee and the place really does go
crazy because she's built such a legacy
with you know television shows smash and
scorpion and then waitress on broadway
and not to mention idol and and all the
stuff that's you know it's it's it's a
nice surprise for the audience if they
don't know that she's coming well anyway
that back to you um
this show was great i mean this show is
so fun i don't know if anyone's ever
seen his pbs shows it's like
it's just such an amazing night of him
telling
really great stories of how he
discovered people how songs came to be
um and you really are just you're you're
so entertaining
just kind of as a final wrap up here
since we are heading into grammy's
weekend it's all about the music here
i'd love to have just each of you kind
of tell me like what music means to you
and why it's so special to you
i mean music has been
such it's been the fabric of my life for
as long as i can remember i don't know
i don't even know who i'd be if i didn't
have music and i've loved every
genre of music that's come along both
genres that i've i mean genres that i've
helped create and genres that i have
nothing to do with i think like today's
music i think if you the weekend bieber
shawn mendes
drake
i mean these guys are killing it they're
just i love the music i don't know how
to make that kind of music but i love it
and um
i have an open mind about it i think
that's what maybe keeps me sort of in
the mix a little bit well david
catherine thank you both so much for
taking the time this morning and i'm
just so happy for the two of you and you
have a beautiful family and
congratulations on everything and i feel
like you guys are still only just
getting started there's so much ahead so
can't wait to have you out here in las
vegas and hey maybe we'll get to catch
up with you when you guys are here
you can experience david foster hitman
tour featuring special guest katherine
mcphee at encore theatre inside the win
on april 20th 22nd and 23rd you can get
your tickets through ticketmaster that
was lovely